Okay, lets go to our scholar from the, let's
go to our caller from the, oh, I don't know.
How about the four 43 area code?
Who's calling today from four, four three.
Uh, my name is Roman from Baltimore.
Hey, how's it going?
Rome?
I'm all good.
Uh, you know, I'm listening to Elizabeth [inaudible]
and uh, loving her, you know, proposals for
2020.
However, I'm sorry, your, your phone just
cut out when you, whose proposals do you like
for 2020?
It is a bit.
Why?
Oh, Warren.
Okay.
Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah, so I'm curious to see, uh, you know,
the proposal, the awesome and everything,
but we can't do anything without, you know,
the Senate.
I've not heard anything.
Plans about retaking the sentence.
I'm curious the thing, I'm curious to hear
what you think about, um, you know, I know
it's difficult in terms of the roadmap or
retaking the center, but what are these a
candidate thing about possibly taking the
senate and we're taking it?
I don't see any path for Democrats to take
the Senate in 2020.
So here's how I'm thinking about this.
Rome, 2020 for the Senate needs to be, so
here's the what 2020 needs to be, expand the
majority in the house, take the White House
back from Donald Trump and at least try not
to lose more than a seat in the Senate.
Because if you look at the map for 2020, it's
tough.
You also have Doug Jones, a Democrat in Alabama
who won barely against a serial accused child
sex assault or, and Roy Moore in the special
election in 2017.
Um, you have, he's trying to defend a seat
in the very red state of Alabama.
So I think that we just need to manage expectations.
It's, I don't see any path for Democrats to
take the Senate in 2020 that is going to limit
what Democrats are able to get past, even
if they do take the White House in November
of 2020 but I think of 2020, like I said,
set up year two then in 2022 hopefully be
able to take control back of the Senate.
But I think the reason you don't hear a lot
of Democrats talking about taking the Senate
in 2020 because most of them know it's just
not going to happen.
Oh, here's how a follow up question one, the
question about, um, who has the best policies
do not avoid it than others than getting in
and getting past?
No, no, no.
You can listen just because you're not going
to pass medicare for all between January of
2021 and January of 2023 which would be like
that two year period doesn't mean that we
don't still want to vote for the person who
has the right proposal and you never know
what they might be able to negotiate with
Republicans in the Senate and a house that
Democrats control.
And then you've got the 2022 elections so
it's not null and void.
I mean, listen, if you say to me, uh, there's
a 5% chance medicare for all gets passed,
um, no matter who is in the White House, merely
because Democrats aren't going to control
the Senate, I still want the person that I
agree with on Medicare for all in the White
House.
It's not null and void at all.
It's just, it might be part of a four or six
year process that starts in 2020.
So my intention was what I said really was
to try to focus more on the 2020 question
in terms of what would be the most important
thing for them.
Think for Democrats, are we looking at electability
on being in trouble or are we looking at,
um, who has the best policies with the guy?
So what can be pass it on?
Right?
I don't even think we need to think of it
that way.
Right now we have a primary, we've seen from
the polling that we've seen all of the top
four or five candidates right now we'll have
a shot at beating Trump and it's going to
come down to turnout.
So right now we just want to hear from the
candidates what are their policies, what are
their positions?
Let's pick the people that we agree with.
Once we have a general election candidate,
then we'll get to try to beat Trump, which
I believe we can do on turnout.
We actually, the differences in terms of the
specific candidates and how they're pulling
against Trump, there are differences, but
ultimately this, this could well be a turnout
election.
So I would not think about it.
I would not now just start thinking about
electability.
Right.
Gotcha.
A piece of work that you're doing and I would
keep the good work up on it.
All right, roam.
Thank you.
Please let, let, let's see if next time we
can get a better connection because you, I
love what you're saying, but I just am having
a hard time hearing a lot of it and that's
never good for anybody.